okay for people who are joining this
livestream we are reviewing some of the
new image audio and signal processing
functionality for a future version of
wolf language so this is kind of a long
list of things here which is good
alright let's start off image contents
in which cases so we we met fairly
recently about that right sorry in the
machine learning meeting we have talked
about this as you know we would still
like to retrain these networks we've
been working with the curation team to
get some consistency between the labels
and the classes of some new datasets
we're using and the old ones we are
ready to try and very soon okay I'm
going to be doing with the sandwich
pattern object business that's not yet
planned I think for 12 No so image cases
it will be pre trained categories of
thing but it will not yet be find an
example of this thing train and find an
example is that true correct I thought
we did have a chance to do that can you
check on that please so I think that's
not impossible so my understanding from
that meeting was that that was looking
you know possible what do you think
Roger about image position versus image
positions plural
well I mean this is not that big a deal
hideaway there's a consistency you know
I I realize position is what you're
thinking of right yeah
I think we should probably call it image
position and just say gives the position
you know what would we say for position
here I think it's okay we should just
call it image position Saudis is that
okay with you yep so with image contains
Q that is analogous I mean that's
analogous to member q in some sense is
that right yes but I think it's utterly
obscure to call it member kill me we do
have some contains type stuff right we
have do we have text contains Q string
contains Q for sure contains any
contains only or we have a family of
some functions with contains content
structure Q yeah okay well fair enough
okay um all right let's go on because
we're gonna I want to get through this
whole agenda and we'll go back on some
of these later yeah we liked it you
likely to want another meaning yeah on
this stuff for sure you know once that
once that's basically running I want to
try it out check sense because I think
there going to be some settings there um
[Music]
the
[Music]
um you know I think we may have to tweak
some things about specificity flush
holds etc for things like image cases
because you know what if there's a you
know what if you have a picture and
there's a few pixels and it thinks it
might be an owl in the tree right mm-hmm
you know how do we deal with that we
have a question on the live stream about
image cases retraining node the
retraining is just something we're doing
once and for all from our curated data
it's not something that will rehab them
unless you're using the image pattern
which I guess still needs some design
because that probably will require
training once and for all right image
pattern object would do the training
presumably so that then the pattern
object once it has been cooked will be
available pre-trained see use correct
yep that's the ideal go okay okay fine
faces good things happening okay face
recognizer
now what is that going to do do we have
a page for that so given a list of faces
okay so that's a single example
a given face right like like something
from the employee directory or something
yep all right yes and that's if you want
to have multiple examples here correct
syntax you could also have multiple
names or the same name on the right hand
side so you could have multiple examples
for the first name that's just two
different syntax I see I see I see I see
just like classify okay fine
and then that third syntax you either
get the same first argument in the same
form in one of the two previous exact as
well function yeah okay I don't really
like this I don't like using that pun of
having the you know training in italics
there we go okay but now here what you
typically get out the default yeah okay
by default a list of the list of names
associated with all recognized faces
face recognized gives a list of names
associated with faces it recognizes or
something is that right correct okay
[Music]
okay that's wonderful
does it work there
Foreman's not in the builds that it
returns classifier function why does it
need a method that should ensure that
eventually yeah that's the current
version and development that needs that
syntax okay so is this correct I can't
see the picture well I'll have to see is
this correct or is this okay very nice
person Pat Clinton there yes but so it
didn't get that one
it didn't get it right because the face
that is in their training in the first
argument is a frontal face right you
can't get that I think that's a
confusing example together
I think that's confusing I think you
should give that as like a second
example but the first example it should
just nail it
okay sure um I'm actually now that you
say the unsure of the copyright of that
example I'll have to check that as well
okay okay okay acceptance threshold did
we go over that already yeah didn't we
have a long discussion in the machine
learning meeting about this in I think
the not the machine learning team
discussion or meeting it was the animal
detection meeting with Etienne Amir
fine fine so this is the same exception
threshold right yes I just
I asked Etienne whether he's gonna
document it with you or not did I get a
response this is what this is my draft
of the page okay I mean it looks okay
but you should check over that in
sorting function that could be used for
many many many things right you should
probably also open find faces this is
okay but but but find I mean that
sorting function is also relevant to
image cases it's also relevant to text
search yep what are we doing for text
search I thought we already had
something like that for text search yes
first was sorting function page existed
in CBS CBS before I see okay so there is
a sorting function option here there has
been activated exactly and all the notes
you see below the page for sorting
function are year old or Kiara's old
notes I repurpose that page that was
already in CBS to be trip and then
usable for five phases fine what the
hell's that mean pacifies specifies a
function to apply
to sort the results of a computation yep
but in particular it is as impact right
if you want the 10 first well no no ten
first is what will bring me in 10 first
you mean one zero first or what are you
saying if you sort it so its ordered in
somewhere I see I see I get it but now
is this a sort by gender someone I'm
asking I think it's a sort by it is
basically yes yeah otherwise a function
function to use to sort the results of a
computation by specializes of the
function by which to sort okay um the
result of a computation no I don't think
so
I think what we want to say sorting
function at some point here we need to
say sorting function arrow F effectively
gives sort by list comma F right yes
okay um all right I understand and this
is good but please make sure that the
other places that the other folks get
contacted about this okay yeah I mean
it's basically
where
I'm wondering if they're also some
things involving file systems where
there also isn't a well-defined order
its things where there isn't a
well-defined order but where we have to
impose in order so what I'm saying I
mean I wonder I could imagine functions
like find instance needing this as well
Roger mmm
maybe you know if you find multiple
instances you mean yeah ten instances of
a triple or something I don't think
it's not like that you know they're
there they're really it's not like a big
set and then you're sort it's like you
construct exactly what you need okay all
right okay all the geometric situations
in which this comes up with and what
about them might okgo nearest doesn't
have this because it's sorted by nearest
distance
[Music]
I'm guessing search search functions web
image search if you have web all you
search and so forth as long as the api's
we use a law for sorting I don't the
glare lab that's a good question to
raise I don't think they allow for very
much sorted they only allow for the
sorting within the gulp that we already
took if you understand what I'm saying
yep but you should contact the service
connect folk about that sure ok let us
go on and I'm gonna leave you let you
sort out the remainder of this page ok
and you should contact Chiara about what
happens with text search there sure okay
next up color image color what is the
recolor sorry what is that that is if
you want to yeah okay that's kind of a
useful version of of changing color okay
in the region specified so it has a
mosque is that right the region of
interest can be specified as a color
like in that first example it's yellow
so it finds the yellow region but you
can give it an explicit mask as well or
you can give it that color neighborhood
wrapper your specimen we are introducing
in 12 that says colors within the 44.5
this sense from that blue okay let's
talk about that name okay so that is the
analog of interval is that right it's
the analog of a number with uncertainty
otherwise known as around mm-hmm wonder
if it should say color around no no I
mean it's it's not anything to do
statistics it's just everything that's
within as a ball and with respect to
some metric yeah and can you specify the
color space to give the metric you can
specify the color distance which which
has a metric in it like it XYZ or
something like that it's you know the
useful ones are Euclidean in LA B and
then some variations of that Euclidean
an RGB space is what should no no no la
be it needs to be a sort of perceptive
color space Steven or it'll be better I
understand that but so you're saying
that a fault is la be space is that
right yes okay fine an la be space is a
zero one type space or not what is that
you mean that this sense no because it
goes beyond L is 0 1 a and B are
negative typically one point something
to one point it it's the fun but it's of
order one it's not a hundred for example
exactly
what I'm thinking about Rocha is what
they're now Alan I mean should we have
this for numbers what would it be for
for I mean a neighborhood you mean just
neighborhood yeah yeah I mean in other
words is that what is the relationship
between neighborhood and around now
prior to statistical I understand but
neighborhood is kind of the uniform you
know the hard disk version of around if
you understand what I'm saying yeah I
mean we do have intervals but bar
intervals are not sort of Center radius
spec which is another way to learn yeah
I understand but these are also
multi-dimensional yes yes I don't see
the immediate you know I mean we
probably will get to that now in another
review later Steven we'll be talking
about vector inequalities a lot you know
Louis might be highly relevant well I'm
just saying
getting old we're getting a lot of
constructs that are sort of high
dimensional you know of all kinds of
things in the language yes so well good
but I'm for some reason other
possible names for this we had a bunch
we thought Oh
originally we had color range I think I
don't like that that suggests sit return
something yeah
color disc not really we had a color
region even the color region right but
it's not a region that's a problem good
because it could be a region but it's
not no it's it's effectively a mask that
gets translated
a mosque in colorspace no masks in the
image space I don't understand that
comic I mean this is representing a cut
so if I were to so if I say color
neighborhood I mean I'll get a color it
will come back as color neighborhood of
a swatch comedy but if I then say
chromaticity plot of color neighborhood
what will it look like it should do
something like what you see in that plot
it doesn't it's not supported yet but it
it should probably just draw all points
like what you have in that illustration
but I understand those I mean what it
should do is probably just highlight it
should probably just make a gray quotes
disk although it won't be circular even
in whatever color space you're
displaying right right is it the case
that the LA B RGB color transformation
is is like not it doesn't disconnect
right it is still a disc it is still
topologically a disc in RGB color space
if it is a disc in a lie B color space
true should be okay
there's something from cattle verify
them good it's a good concept it is a
good concept
alright um find match in color
what's it gonna return
okay so it finds the red learn that
image exactly this is not quite English
looks into the dominant colors
please don't use doesn't we don't do
that does not I'll change that just not
the style we use here I don't think you
should say what it looks at dominant
colors I mean you are you are you are
you saying that it is that it always
uses the dominant colors thing there is
this note we could take it leather
literal and say that we are looking into
what dominant colors returns but also
conceptually what happens if you have a
single pixel that is red it doesn't get
returned because I say I say considers
the dominant colors one takes the
dominant colors of the image and returns
any color at find a color a color it
finds close to color yes okay max color
distance
and annoying that we have to have is
this an old option yes well I did not
know about it okay are these old options
min color distance yeah well I don't
know about those
I have never dug into donut colors I
just use the default yes I didn't have
to ever look that's good because it is
quite slow dominant colors has been
quite slow yeah
color quantize by the way there was a
very good kid at the summer campus here
who implemented a bunch of color
dithering algorithms um if and that's I
mean we are using dithering for color
quantizes that right or what we don't
have we just have one algorithm
implemented I know where there are just
just implemented a whole bunch of
algorithms okay um hopefully he's going
to continue to be involved with us you
can contact probably suite we'd have the
information or Andrea Griffin okay and
you can also just look at
summer camp tumblr and your fine thing
about the ring it's quite quite a nice
piece of work actually okay one argument
form color quantize you always had to
provide how many colors you want to
quantize to be able to just guess how
many I agree I agree
okay image D mosaic what's that about
it's it's an older function version nine
I believe and it needs a lot of updates
I'm still waiting to wrap up development
to see whether it can make it to 12
owner summary we're gonna have hopefully
some more algorithms
it's the sensor data that comes in and
you convert that to an RGB image or a
color image please if we're gonna use
this function can we please put it in
the spelling dictionary all email what
is it - gun from from cameras you get
RAW images back the other single channel
you get there as the SSD day that right
yeah the sensor data image the mosaicing
is the process of getting converting
that raw data into RGB data typically
you have patterns like that are ggb
pattern so you have half of the pixels I
see I see this is the truly raw image
which automatically when we do import we
are converting it are we not yes ok so
this is if it does import of a raw okay
so if you take if you do import on a raw
format is there an import element that
gives you this pure pixel by pixel
you know what the CCD sees type version
yes its raw raw image or raw data versus
data or ami so hopefully you can show
that in the
example exact here of T mosaic right
okay
and hopefully this has some reasonable
keywords that would actually allow me to
find this because I would never know a
lot date there I would talk about things
like CCD array but I'm even gonna add
CCD array even um color sensor array
I don't know lots of other things like
that would probably list cameras and
roll formats and so forth yes that would
be good too whatever okay all right
let's keep going
microscopy it's a guide page soon
okay
so there are new things here or what no
Jessica wait is this a new guide page
yes I think it the title is a little
weird hard to understand why don't we
call it computational microscopy or
something let's object to that I think
the word microscopy has to be a narrow
the microscope we need to add a lot more
to something like computational
microscopy other than other than image
processing for microscopy
I just think microscope image processing
microscope can be a verb in modern times
and super confusing Roger yeah I think I
think that sounds good image processing
for microscope
no no I'm suggesting image processing
for microscopy cross copy I cross copy
I think then this sets the tone nicely
for a bunch of other image processing
for xxx
I agree plus we want to say image
computation for microscopy would be more
correct as we do a lot of analysis as
well
why are we really listening I mean if
it's a microscope why are we doing web
image search I mean that's a very sort
of secondary thing I agree we can yeah
we can probably remove this current
image I mean well this current image
work if you've connected a microscope if
so it should say that it's gone so you
should say that hey should make that a
separate line here because that might be
super useful to people and again I can't
say I mean if that's important to
microscopy and by the way this is
following that dot dots it doesn't come
with a link there and it should if it's
going to be a dot dot dot well there's a
lot of interesting stuff here I mean
obviously image cases will be of high
interest here mm-hmm
okay fine thing okay image type I have
no opinion about this what is this one
among the
types for image and audio we had real
which was representing real 64 for a
while with the numeric array updates and
and others we decided to be explicit we
always support that both real and real
64 when constructing born this is the
only place that is going to be backwards
incompatible and we are now returning
well hopefully there aren't too many
places where people have done a test
right you might look at our code base
and see if there are we have done that
this this change has been in a prototype
for a long time okay
dynamic image oh boy hasn't best have we
seen this creature before this image
pyramid thing before yes
it's what is the point of this thing
really for relating to dynamic image
this is gonna be a fast efficient way of
accessing the image at different
resolutions so we compute different
resolutions once and then as we zoom and
pan we just use the level that we need
why isn't it an image camera pyramid
function here it will be
you mean the return the result yeah the
data go away okay so what is it going to
become just the image pyramid or is it
kind of come here image a separate image
pyramid function it's no no it's gonna
be an image pyramid so image parameters
only both the constructor and the
container okay
so image pyramid this thing either
curried of seven or something or comma
seven what would comma seven give you
does it give you a list up to seven or
does it give you just the seventh the
nth level I see and level the Gaussian
pyramid I think that's whatever this is
look honestly this is a
obscure function and I would almost
consider calling it something like image
multi-resolution pyramid or something
because otherwise you see image pyramid
in you know in a random piece of code
and it's like you know is this is this
an ancient Egyptian of Asian invasion or
something
am i making sense yeah it's been always
very intuitive to me what it is but I
see your point
yeah I mean why not call it a mich
multi-resolution pyramid or something or
image what what is the right what is its
full name you see that it can also
contain the difference pyramid right the
when you specify the pyramid type in
that illustration you could have the
multi resolution image which is the
Gaussian pyramid or you could have the
laplacian pyramid and then there are
various other methods including one that
we've included reasons is this really
the right thing here I mean this is
really a it is another form of okay what
would happen if I wanted an image
represented by an orca tree or something
quad tree rather
it's sort of a simplified wavelet
okay but I mean if I wanted a um I
notice flip-flops on our live stream
saying that this thing is used a lot in
I mean Vision Research and he has a
dozen implementations mainly of gaussian
pyramids um that's interesting okay but
but i just trying to understand if i was
going to give a quadtree representation
of this image instead for instance isn't
that another way of giving sort of a
multi resolution version no why not core
trees and oak trees are used for M for
geometric search and they though isn't
there a version where I just I guess
it's not as useful as this well whatever
maybe I'm just confused but I mean if I
if I go down and I say you know I'm
imagining something where there's
meshing down to a certain level right
and where some parts of the image are
just showing that's only level four or
something which is a big blob and some
parts are shown at level 8 where it's
much finer right like a like like a mesh
that's been refined in some places no
III got it but it's it him oak trees and
quadtrees it's this geometric data
structure but it's it's not used for it
it's used for geometric search is used
to locate things quickly by not look by
avoid and I understand that baby okay
what is this
how does the thing actually work what is
what does it do look at a few
application examples I think I think if
you look at fusion or or removing noise
at different levels or
you
you
what are you doing here I don't
understand these examples the first one
was finding lines at different scales
the second one is blending two images at
different resolutions I see
but so
you
I guess I'm still a little confused here
about what you actually do so one issue
is the thing is that you build the
pyramid okay
and then you can decide that you want to
let sit for instance you want to apply a
filter at one of the levels
that
and that tells you sort of how how fine
you do it you know so some some things
are very visible at low level
some are very high level yes and and you
can you can also combine two different
stacks that was diffusion or blending
case down there okay you know comments
slopes comments that image perm is
generic object the contents of each
level the pyramid is specific I Gaussian
x' laplacian x' differences etc um I
don't quite understand that comment so
in other words the question of whether
you extract a laplacian is a subsequent
decision is that right
it's not the nature of the pyramid
itself it is merely what the pyramid
outputs weight I think you can
reconstruct the image from the laplacian
s-- just as you can from the gaussians
but the laplacian is what gets stored in
the pyramid not not what the pyramid
returns so if you you
the ploy clubs no I'm confused no place
in pyramid the top level that level 4
there is not a difference anymore that's
just a more resolution image similar to
what you have in the Gaussian and then
if you want a reconstruction of a
Gaussian pyramid is just a resampling of
or just extracting one of those levels
but reconstruction of the laplacian
pyramid is up sample at the details of
sample at the details until you get to
the resolution you want right I notice
on our live stream more comments about
people saying that this is useful not
only in the image registration okay so I
just want to make sure because I don't
fully understand this I just want to
make sure that we're packaging this
correctly in other words if somebody
wants to use this in
I mean it's sounding like this is
something where you often want to get
level such-and-such of the pyramid to do
things that is that right or am i
confused or is it something where you
will simultaneously operate at all
levels in some way both I would say okay
what's an example of a case where you
would so I understand you know you go to
level 2 or something and I mean I'm not
quite sure why that's different from
just blurring the image in some way or
down some rather down sampling the image
in some way example we're gonna have an
immediate use for it in dynamic image as
I said it's just everything precomputed
you have it you access the right
resolution at the right time
I get that but I guess what I'm asking
is what's the difference between in the
case where you're doing let's see I mean
these are
kill these powers of two levels of down
sampling or what that's that's yeah by
default but you have the scaling factor
in the fourth argument I see okay but so
well I'm trying to understand okay so
look first point you know how analogous
wavelets for example have not been in a
big success for us so I don't really
understand the notion of like operations
on wave lettered things if you
understand what I'm saying like for a
Fourier series I understand a Fourier
transform I understand you go to the
frequency domain you do you operate on
it you go back yeah you sort of do that
for wavelets - no I understand that but
in this case you're not doing that
because this is not some kind of this is
a different kind of creature no you
can't do that here - you know some of
the applications if you look in those
applications we have also that inverse
image pyramid that you may have missed
well I saw that yeah
Flip Phillips wants to get a copy of
this right away and it's commenting also
that in computer graphics texture maps
have been stored this way since the
1980s that's right mm-hmm okay but so
this is extremely encouraging that
people are interested in this
functionality I still want to understand
whether it's packaged correctly so the
way this works if I'm understanding you
is image pyramid see you say returns all
levels does it return a list or no it
returns a function it returns itself as
a package thing which can then be
carried on to I don't understand this at
all because the curried you know it can
be carried on to n to get the nth level
so correct yes okay
and that sighs I wish you wouldn't do
this given sighs I wish you wouldn't do
this thing of doing this pun of having
the the the italic thing be used as the
name if you get what I'm saying given
number of pixels specified by size or
something
mm-hmm anyway um they okay but the thing
I'm trying to understand is given this
packaged image pyramid function
effectively which here you can extract
level n from what else do you do with it
so there is another function called
image pyramid apply oh okay this is
where things start to get more
complicated okay fine modify images
wasn't a call them as pyramid map
because we have image apply instead of
image map
I see
confusion with map images geographic map
right okay so applies f as a gulp to all
images so it's not applying to pixels
like image apply applies to pixels right
correct so it could have a different
name and perhaps should have a different
name not applying to pixels it's
applying to each image in the pyramid
correct and what would that function
what kind of function would you
typically apply to each image in the
pyramid one example we had was that
gradient filter computation another one
that we had was the split assemble okay
but the image the the gradient
computation gives you kind of lines and
thickened lines and so on mm-hmm and
then what do you do you you composite
them all together to get where any line
of any thicknesses yes
okay I'm not buying the apply word here
because I think it's different from its
apply and it's useful to make that
distinction and I'm confused about why
oh I see
because image pyramid okay so let's just
go through this again image pyramid is
returning an image pyramid object
basically yes although it's it's self
you know it's an it's a kind of self
representing creature and that thing can
be carried onto an integer to give that
particular level to give her an image a
plane plane image at that level of the
image pyramid is that correct
correct okay meanwhile you can take the
whole image pyramid object and map
doesn't work on it I mean why is it
useful well okay all right okay but why
is it useful to have an image pyramid
object rather than just to have a list
of the images at the levels of the
pyramid where you can extract the nth
element of it and so on it's just so
that we don't have to keep track of the
pyramid type and the scaling factor
possibly the padding value used and
things like that all the details okay
everything is stored in the object
okay so inverse image pyramid how does
it how does it recompose it because I
mean there might be it might disagree I
mean I might have turned one level green
and one level purple right what would it
do in that case
do you see what I'm saying I didn't get
your example so let's imagine that I
took the levels in the image pyramid I
made the top one red the second one well
level 2 red level 3 purple and then I
say inverse image pyramid presumably
that is attempting to reconstruct a
single image from that right mm-hmm okay
what does it do if there's an
incompatibility between the levels well
I guess still if you have the Gaussian
pyramid what happens is that if you want
to extract something at the size of say
a thousand by a thousand pixel it looks
for the image at that size or larger
than that the first image larger than
that and then resamples back to the
requested size so if that ends up being
the red image you get a red result back
and then if the resolution is lower than
the purple image you get the purple
image back
I don't currency we're not doing any
content check for the images we do check
that the pyramid has the right image
dimensions and compatible color spaces
and things like that across all images
stored in the pyramid but we don't do
any content check
looks to me like Flip Phillips is quite
an expert in this area um and it might
be worth having a conversation with them
I'll flyer here um because I'm a little
concerned about the the piece is talking
about pyramid based algorithms um
and I just I don't quite understand what
I mean
the basic idea would be you're going
into pyramid space effectively just like
you go into free a space you're doing
something there and then you're coming
back is that right
I'm confused about what right I'm a
little confused about how that really
works and I'm confused about what the
analog I mean in the wavelet case we
have I mean the wavelets it's sort of an
orthogonal collection of things that you
get whereas here the successive levels
of the pyramid have no orthogonal to my
making sense
all right I think you guys should reach
out to flip and try and make sure that
we're I mean unless yeah please all
right I just want to
have a quick look through here because
we're over time for this um dynamic
image is still experimental right yes I
mean is dynamic image so dynamic in
which comes from something outside of
the notebook true or not true
the content of it the other content it
could actually be either a path to a
file or an actual image in the kernel
okay okay but in the case where it's a
file I'm concerned about the management
of that
okay because I mean what the issue is
what happens and it's just like our same
issue with data set and with these other
with audio and so on where we're now
having that footer that says do you want
to include it with the notebook right
I think that would be useful for dynamic
image as well but maybe at some point
scary if the image is too big well I
understand and I think what what you
know what we're ultimately going for is
the notebook bundle um where we can
manage that a little bit better but I
think we don't want a situation where
people are routinely having dynamic
images and they're just going off into
lala land I mean now I assume is there
any meaningful way that a dynamic image
can run against the cloud presumably it
can structurally I mean there's nothing
stops it doing that and if you use the
local cash function it will cash into a
local object on your machine as needed
mm-hmm will that just work so you're
thinking of us of dynamic image itself
uploading to a cloud object and then
keeping that as a reference as a backup
reference
he is what I'm saying I'm saying that
that way because that way if it's a
public cloud object people can access it
one thing we've been thinking about
audio out of karate oh is to be able to
interactively and programmatically do
these kinds of location storage location
specification you have a local file you
want to store it on the cloud there
might be a button there might be a
programmatic way okay so listen there's
a whole structure for this it's the
whole persistent value structure that we
just built some okay so let me just show
you something like persistence location
there's this whole giant list of
persistence locations where things can
be persisted with a kernel session
notebook local local shared cloud and
then these things like cookie managed
and so on
right so this is this is probably the
way to do it is to use persistent value
in some fashion um or to use similar
persistence locations because that's
really the issue is what you know how
yeah how persistent do you want it to be
um flip is saying on our live stream
that he'd be happy to chat
Thank You um okay all right I don't
think we're gonna get to the stuff today
but let me just just have a quick look
ahead yeah speech recognizer how is that
doing it hasn't changed due to the
summer school compared to what you've
seen but structurally it was working
right yes the people who are working on
speech recognizer but not at the summer
school so that's not an excuse I'm
really going to buy into
um Pitts recognized okay
is that was that I understand that
comment because speech recognizer has
been worked on by people had nothing to
do with a summer school actually you're
right but still no updates on that it's
still the matter of speed and some
interval detection for the words I don't
like frequency range as being an option
for pitch recognizer frequency range is
too generic of term
should be something like
[Music]
you know a loud frequency range or
something am i making sense okay because
currency range could be something where
you're asking what is the frequency
range of this stuff and so on you can I
just try I just want to try this because
I think it's cool um okay so if I say
audio capture and oh for God's sake do I
can I can I do this anyway well give it
I hadn't seen this before sorry hello
hello hello dead in the water
no will this working in the non
prototype build pitched recognized is
not their speech right miss please
recognize that no none of them are
merged into master okay do we have
example data that has some interesting
[Music]
look for audio instead of sound well do
we have one small step or whatever at
that one we have we have a male's voice
and a female voice as well okay so let's
try this one for example so this is
example theta okay so this is hopefully
going to be some audio why is this
taking forever why is this doing this
[Music]
something broken in the prototype build
and that explanation right that's a
device update I have seen that before
okay so if I say speech recognizer here
of that right yep
it's gonna go grind grind grind it's a
good mani it would be nice if this is
really gonna take a long time is it
going to take a long time or is it just
loading something I'm guessing once
things are low that right it's
downloading now it should be in the
matter of seconds for this 10 10 or so
seconds audio
what's it doing that what it downloaded
to nil nuts yes one for speech
recognition itself one for language
module exactly
okay let's just see what this does
ah yes sorry yeah neural network
framework still has issues in today's
prototype build okay fine
oh well would have been nice to see okay
okay
this aurélie thing there was a crazy
correspondence with that peg about that
and it's useful golly
mm-hmm um we publish to talk about that
separately all right so we need at least
another hour for all of this stuff yeah
um
Eric is Eric here I don't know um all
right anyway this is looking great let's
look forward to seeing the next next
round and thanks to folks on the
livestream and talk to y'all soon